i saw that the mainstream media was not
covering this and that to me was very
eerie
it infuriated me that our leaders had
just condemned
people to essentially starve for the
first time in history
china might be deliberately influencing
this now we know
that it was all just theater they have
these videos of people just collapsing
on the street
which mysteriously appeared all over the
international internet
right around the time that wuhan locked
down the only way to stop it
was just chinese totalitarianism you
bring up the fact that they're wearing
masks and
you know i'll go into a restaurant with
my mask on as soon as i get the table i
take it off
where do we how do we get back to normal
the reason they love these masked
mandates is that
they spread anxiety they spread fear
[Music]
welcome back to generally speaking i'm
your host general spalding and i'm here
with
michael singer who is what i consider to
be
a part of the fourth estate he is
a twitter influencer but he's also
working to expose the chinese communist
party's influence on our society
and it's in a very interesting way i
became aware of mike through his efforts
on exposing a lot of the influence that
the chinese communist party has
placed within our medical institutions
and so we're going to talk about a
letter that he
helped put together and i'm really
excited and i think you're going to
enjoy the conversation
and let's welcome mike singer to the to
the program
you wrote this letter and he kind of
contacted me out of the blue
and said hey would you take a look at
this so can you explain a little bit
about the letter that that you
put together and and how how long you
worked on it
um to because it's i think with
citations it's like 150 pages um
uh when i paste it into a word uh word
doc so it's a pretty
pretty it's it's it's more than a letter
it's kind of like a you know a report a
pretty
a pretty interesting report but you know
how did you how did you come about
to to do that and who did you enlist to
help
right thanks general um so it's really
kind of a long story
you know this caught my interest as soon
as the world started shutting down
before that i was not
i didn't really know much about chinese
influence like for
the vast majority of people it's very
sort of hidden you don't really know
about it until you get into this
community and something sort of draws
you in whether it's military experience
or some kind of
experience with the intelligence
community or some kind of experience in
journalism that really triggers this
interest and you start digging deeper
into it but
you know when i saw one country after
another start to shut down like this in
march
and sort of this very eerie way of
just stop all economic activity and
you know when italy did it i'm like okay
that's strange maybe i didn't know
as much about italy as i thought then
when i saw united states and the united
states doing it you see california
shutting down
and to me it's like wait a minute that
is totally antithetical to everything
you know the united western state like
california i mean that has nothing to do
with the history of the sort of
wild west state to just have the
government forcibly shut down all
economic activity
so i immediately knew that was you know
very strange thing to happen
and then as i saw this policy spread to
developing countries you see
africa countries in africa shut down
india shuts down
and at that point i knew you know these
leaders are essentially just condemning
people
to to starve like this is very wrong
something has to be wrong here they got
something very wrong and that
that got me researching digging deeper
into this
and realizing that this was not
all about born of course by that point
it was already sort of common knowledge
that
the chinese communist party had a lot of
influence in the world health
organization
and so this hypothesis formed very early
that they might be using
this china might be influencing this
pandemic response
and so i got involved in the sort of
anti-lockdown community
um because i saw that the mainstream
media was not covering this
and that to me was very eerie and of
course you know
at first i just thought it was group
think i thought they were being woke
they were being
sort of patriotic by just buying into
this
uh these lockdowns without any sort of
real debate in the mainstream media
um before this you know i was just sort
of your typical liberal
very sort of left-wing professional i
would read the new york times the
economist the wall street journal
that was really all the social media
interaction i ever did just commenting
on you know mainstream sites
but it infuriated me that
our leaders had just condemned people to
essentially starve just destroyed
everyone's livelihoods for the first
time in history this never happened
before
and there was no debate about this that
struck me as
just you know
i i mean i could never even imagine
anything like that happening
so and i heard that started here about
others
who had this same reaction that i did
that i was not alone in this
that um you know you know michael berry
the genius from the big short
he was an early sort of whistleblower
that you know in his
mind he um you know he's slightly
autistic
for him he immediately realized that the
effects of this were going to be
absolutely catastrophic this would be
the most catastrophic policy
decision that he'd ever seen in his
lifetime so i started
i joined twitter started following him
started following others and the
anti-lockdown community um
you know alex berenson is a former
reporter for the new york times has been
very active
but i think for most of the
anti-lockdown community especially in
the early days
there was a real feeling that this is
just sort of a scientific mix up like
the scientists you know
they got this wrong they didn't realize
how widespread the virus was
um they thought this was going to work
and we just show them data we clear this
up and we go on our way like this is
just a
this big mistake and that's it and i
wasn't so sure
and in the beginning that was a sort of
radical view that
china might be deliberately influencing
this
um and so i started getting more
involved in the uh
china watching community on twitter as
well and sort of
so i sort of bridged those two
communities which very few people were
doing
you know getting involved with
intelligence folks um china experts
started following them
uh folks in the the hong kong protest
movement was very big back then
and started learning much more about the
way that
china had been sort of buying up
um influence in universities
uh think tanks uh mainstream media and
essentially sort of warping the truth
over a very long term in their favor
and that sort of started to explain
you know how we could how they might be
influencing this across the entire world
with so little
debate this uh pandemic response and
then around
sort of may june um there was a real
smoking gun
where the new york times wrote a really
good expose
of a lot of the propaganda that um
that china was putting out on social
media and it doesn't seem like the
authors
of the new york times article really
understood exactly what they had found
but it turns out if you
dig deeper into this article into their
sources
you find just thousands and thousands of
these tweets
essentially sort of you know saying hail
china's lockdown policy likes praising
china's lockdown policies sort of sort
of denigrating leaders across the entire
world
um for not implementing these policies
and
so i dug deeper into that and started
doing these sort of bot maps of all
these you know fake accounts that were
um essentially promoting lockdowns all
across the world with all these
different leaders and pressuring leaders
to implement these
and that was sort of the initial threat
i did and i started my account sort of
for that specific purpose of trying to
say you know
china might be deliberately using
propaganda to promote this
and um from there it kind of
one thing led to another i started
getting deeper into it and
yeah obviously it's not just propaganda
it's the influence they have in public
health as well
and um it turns out that a lot of the
scientific journals i started uncovering
scientific journals and getting in
contact with people who
uh were involved in the scientific
community some investigative journalists
started
sending me assume from information about
some of the initial
scientific journals with the
recommendations for
putting people on ventilators way too
early which could be very deadly
uh those recommendations all came from
china the idea that this was a novel
virus
um which is dubious it's really just
kind of an ordinary coronavirus that
you know concept came from china that i
did come from china
the entire idea of lockdown had
absolutely no precedence within public
health it was not part of any other
epidemic playbooks
and you know the united states the
united kingdom were
ranked you know on the very top in terms
of epidemic preparedness
but the idea of lockdown had never been
taken seriously it was just utterly
dismissed
until xi jinping general secretary of
the chinese communist party
ordered it and immediately when he did
you know the world
health organization is just besides
themselves is this the greatest policy
ever
that didn't have any results to show for
this lockdown
uh she had just locked everybody into
their homes you know
sealed people's doors shuts off without
enough food
uh there were big protests in wuhan
um but the world health organization
ever and as soon as
you know the chinese communist party
started saying oh we flattened the curve
and
the data is obviously forged but um the
representative from the world
health organization in china uh
announced that this is a huge success
and recommend the entire world follow us
and
now we know that it was all just theater
like we have many many studies showing
that
the coronavirus is always already very
widespread across many countries by the
end of 2019
and this wuhan lockdown did not even go
into effect
until january late january
so this is just all theater um
and it i mean we don't know if it
actually accomplished anything probably
didn't accomplish anything
is one city in china that shut down
and this was laundered into public
health policy based on that one city
and the entire world was ordered to do
this
and everyone fell in line and that's
really how much
influence the chinese communist party
has and it's i mean it's just
um it's baffling to me that they have
that much influence i think that's
extraordinarily scary
what part did your legal training play
in kind of how you researched this and
you know like i said it's a very well
cited paper um you know extensive
citations in it where you show
for example imperial college of london
and their initial test or not tests but
their report
on the the potential
threat of over two million americans
dying was so
widely off the mark uh and it was
interesting to note that
in i think 2015 you you
xi jinping himself visits imperial
college and gives them a big grant for
doing things like epidemiological
research so you know what what what role
did your
did your background have in legal
training to
begin to research this and who did you
who did you enlist to help out
yeah um yeah that is a funny story with
imperial college
no i i think you know my legal training
definitely has
helped in that sense of just um
quality of evidence and you know
gathering evidence
yeah it's very clear when you read the
letter that
you know everything is cited every
single
um point of evidence is cited
meticulously
almost every sentence is cited that's a
very that's very common in legal writing
because when lives are in the balance
when you're arguing in front of a judge
you know you can't just say something
everything has to be
true it has to be very meticulously
decided because there's somebody on the
other side
are you the exact opposite thing so uh
if they can point a hole in something
and say you didn't cite that you know
you don't have evidence for that
um they will say so so you know my
sources sort of
send me stuff all over the place and i'd
say you know 90
of what i do is filtering out what is
high enough quality
to actually be evidence and ultimately
that letter is
i mean if i included everything that i
had from
everywhere and a lot of it is sort of
mostly circumstantial evidence things
that
are almost you know sort of borderline
conspiratorial
but i mean it would not be 100 pages it
would be a thousand pages
so a lot of what i do is sort of
filtering that stuff out i think my
legal
training has helped me a lot in that and
also you know i was an auditor before
doing a law um
you know i i do have a specific
background that might have
been sort of why me people have asked
and asked why
me why you know has this apparently sort
of evaded a lot of the intelligence
community which is a story in itself
and sort of you are the one to if this
is real
if the chinese communist party is
influenced in the world but debit
response
why are you the one to be sort of the
the champion of this cause
um and i i think it's because i have
sort of backgrounded economics
uh background as an auditor just sort of
um
background doing this type of forensic
investigative work and also background
law and you know um working at this
quality of evidence and doing this type
of legal writing so
uh i do in some ways sort of have that
unique set of skills that might have
just sort of
made me attune to this so yeah with
imperial college um
that was a big part of the story and um
it's easy to forget but this is not a
connection that most people had made
several months ago actually when i first
started
reporting on china's propaganda lockdown
propaganda
a lot of folks who say well i don't know
how much influence that would really
have these online propaganda campaigns
you know what really did the trick was
neil ferguson's model the imperial
college model predicting all these
deaths
and so that scared people it terrified
people
they started people um and you have that
sort of multi-tiered approach where
at the sort of base emotional level
you have the propaganda that comes right
through people's screens of saying like
you know in 10 days you're going to be
just like italy you're going to have
overrun hospitals
you know you have to do what china did
and you know look at china how great
that is
and then have these videos of people
just collapsing on the street right
they just collapse on the street yep
just over a year ago you know people are
now
bringing back those images of people
collapsing on the street in china which
mysteriously appeared all over the
international internet
right around the time that wuhan locked
down um
sites that are all blocked in china so i
don't know how you explain that and of
course
a year later that has not happened
anywhere else in the world
um it was all theater for um which
audience
i mean given that it was released all
over the world uh
apparently in an international audience
and that in a lot of ways kind of tells
you everything you didn't know right
there i mean
um the chinese communist party was
trying to scare the world
with this propaganda but anyway um
so it's a passive approach and so people
questioned sort of
how effective would that propaganda be
by itself and that's true
but it was not just propaganda you had
the models as well and you had the
scientific journals
so you know folks were asking what about
that initial model it seems like that
was really sort of the biggest factor in
getting the scare in the entire world
and shutting down
and so i started looking more into
imperial college and some folks had
alerted me to the fact that
if your world college actually has a
very special relationship with china
of any you know university in the
western hemisphere
imperial college has the closest
relationship with the chinese communist
party
and as you said in 2015 xi jinping
actually
took a very short trip to the united
kingdom only four days
his only trip to the united kingdom is
general secretary and happened to make a
big stop
imperial college to announce all these
new collaborations
and public health and um you know
biological research
that are very much a point here so i
mean what does that tell you
and to this day you know imperial
college still announces that they have
this very close relationship with china
um very close collaborations with china
and gets a lot of their funding from
china in all sorts of ways so
very telling because throughout this
entire crisis
the models coming out of imperial
college have been wildly off the mark
um they have been far and away the most
inaccurate and the study from
ucla proved this that um compare the
accuracy
of various mainstream universities and
institutions
models of predicted deaths and imperial
colleges are
always far too high so always off and
not just always off but always off in
one direction of being far too alarmist
and
far too high and they happen to have
this very special relationship with
china
um you know i can't go
i am not a police officer i cannot go
question people
but i don't understand why you would not
because that to me is a very
uh strange connection there and so i
hope somebody
looks more into that so when people look
at you you know
um and particularly after this comes out
and
now that you're you know a twitter
influencer do do you get the impression
that they
uh think that you're some kind of
crackpot or a
tinfoil hat wearing person i mean have
people come after you have the chinese
come after you
i mean what's what's been um you know
how have has your paper
been received so
it's been received very well the
response has been very positive
um i can't say you know
it it's still not considered mainstream
and especially in the early days um you
know when i was just researching the
propaganda that was that was a very
common response that you know
a very dismissive you know the world did
not shut down because of a bunch of
tweets and that's true
it wasn't a bunch of bunch of tweets and
that's why you know i went on from
writing just about propaganda
to this letter detailing all the
scientific fraud that took place in all
the
science journals on asymptomatic spread
the initial pcr
test genomes coming from china i mean
everything we know about this virus
the entire response has come from china
they
you know had that controlled the initial
information about this virus and
everything our entire response from
lockdowns to the ptr test to the idea
that was novel
and asymptomatic spread all came from
the chinese communist party
and that's not good given that this is
well known to be a totalitarian country
now
um so initially i think people
thought it was maybe a little
you know out there to think that the
chinese communist party was
um deliberately manipulating this
because initially i think most folks who
are against lockdowns just thought it
was a scientific misunderstanding
and that if we just clear up the science
and we have enough charts and graphs
making this very clear that
lockdowns are not good then that will
change things
um and that has not turned out to be the
case
and that is why my following has grown
so much
over the past several months because i
think it's become
more and more clear to anybody with
their eyes open that
our leaders are for one reason or
another
using this pandemic to turn the world
into china um
you know now we have they've introduced
tracing apps they've introduced the idea
of mandatory vaccines in a lot of
countries
they've introduced um you know vaccine
passports they go on freedom passes in
the united kingdom
which is an idea that comes straight
from xi jinping he wants to set up this
world global
you know um biometric database
uh we have censorship we have propaganda
we have these
massive civil attacks we have the idea
of lockdown itself
which came straight from shooting pain
has now become this you know
common idea uh everybody walks around
with
masks it just obviously
came from china so it's become more and
more clear to folks that
you know our leaders are
turning us into china and
folks want to know why that is um
there's still
a lot of people who think this is just
you know public health
people being a bit gullible um
still just kind of a scientific
misunderstanding they think like hey
this worked in china
and so we should probably try it here uh
you know i think given the level of
sycophancy
i see from a lot of folks in public
health um
toward china i think there's a bit more
to it than that
um especially you know some of the
quotes you see you see
you know the world health organization
just bending over backwards to
praise china for its lockdowns you know
very prematurely announcing that it was
a success when
that was obviously not true and it's
very clear to anybody
that the virus is still spreading around
china
you have the um editor in chief
of the world's premier medical journal
the lancet
saying you know just very
this very sycophantic article that had
absolutely nothing to do with public
health say
that you know all of china's leaders
have had the interest of securing
the territorial integrities that cured
by mao zedong it was just
the very strange you know pro ccp
article that you know the global times
could have written
um so it i mean it's
to me it's very clear that
you have this virus from china
in a public health response from china
that is
turning the world into china and
it's considered sort of mainstream to
think that china is not deliberately
influencing that that you have this
very prosperous um totalitarian country
very powerful totalitarian country
that is not influencing the fact that
the entire world is
being turned into china i find that
actually to be the absurd argument here
um
when you look at what has happened over
the past year
what you've seen is the sort of
mainstream embrace of
what is essentially science fiction the
idea that you have this super virus out
there that might have come from a lab
and we don't know if it's a bio weapon
or not
but it's the only way to stop it was
just chinese totalitarianism the great
chinese government was the only super
government
great enough to beat this virus with
this super lockdown that they had in
wuhan
and so everybody has to do exactly what
they didn't have to have lockdown that's
a
mass they have to have mass testing and
tracing and quarantine centers
that is science fiction we have plenty
of data just very self-explanatory
charts that show this is a very ordinary
coronavirus
uh we should never have abandoned our
very sort of light
touch public health plans that we had
centuries of research proving that was
the best
method just you know wash your hands
basic hygiene protect the vulnerable
um that's what public health was always
about we had absolutely no reason to
abandon that
and the reason we did was frankly the
influence of the chinese communist party
and the results have been absolutely
catastrophic it's been the
greatest crime of the 21st century so
you know
the mainstream has embraced the science
fiction story of the super virus
the real story is you know
has something that happened all
throughout history straight out of
ancient greece and ancient rome
the tyrant instructed his cronies to
suspend everyone's rights
and that's exactly what they did i mean
these people are in
the chinese communist party's pocket one
way or the other
or they're being influenced through
various vestiges of the chinese
communist party
and um have convinced people that
they have to give up all their rights to
fight this virus
and unfortunately that's been
extraordinarily effective and
the only way to fight back is to bring
the truth to light about what's really
happened here
the um so obviously the
um the medical industry cdc world health
organization are highly influenced by
the pharmaceutical industry
of course we know the pharmaceutical
industry itself there was a
drugs inc i think that was written about
the you know
all the precursors and just about every
pharmaceutical is manufactured in china
so there's a tight tie between
the chinese communist party and the
pharmaceutical industry
so in your mind is it more
this effect of their influence on the
pharmaceutical
industry who then imparts its influence
on the medical industry you know with
regard to like the cdc and
who or is it also direct influence of
those organizations through
uh collaboration at a government level
yeah now that's uh you know that's where
it gets very tricky
is exactly how the narrative is sort of
being spun and being controlled and
actually who's doing it um now there's
absolutely no question
that the chinese communist party has
been very active in
co-opting scientific institutions and
also the vaccine industry
um you know i think there's been reports
out of several countries uh
one that i recall as canada a
collaboration between
china and canada and it turns out that
it was part of the uh
united front the thousand talents
program where the heads of this
um company this uh vaccine company
were actually co-opting people for to
work for the chinese communist party
so there's no question that the chinese
communist party has been very active in
influencing this area now a lot of this
is
also companies doing what's in their own
financial self-interest there's
absolutely no question about that
and that's a common sort of you know
every day i get posts about how oh you
know it's not just the ccp it's also
you know the world economic forum it's
you know all these corporations doing
what's in their own interests
that is absolutely right that is there's
no question that
once lockdowns started steamrolling
and you know big corporations started
profiting at the expense of small
businesses
a lot of corporations jumped on board
and that combined with sort of
the influence that the chinese communist
party has in these organizations
and also them sort of protecting their
financial interests in china
have made them in some ways since the
bowl actually got rolling almost sort of
indistinguishable
from the chinese communist party because
they're pursuing what's in their own
financial self-interest and once that
idea of lockdown
becomes normalized then
often what is in their financial
self-interest is
contrary to what is really in the
interest of the people's rights
um by the way this is this is what i
um you know back in 2014 when i was
studying
uh and i had a team um of uh folks
officers studying the chinese communist
party at the pentagon
this was the thing that that i realized
was that you know because we had opened
up our society and allowed them to come
in
that they had shifted the incentive
system away from you know
where a u.s company was incentivized to
do things
you know in the common good by the rules
and laws of our system
and in actuality with globalization and
openness we had allowed them to
essentially
take over that incentive system to drive
company behavior
that was in the interest of the chinese
communist party by
one the market pool of 1.4 billion
consumers and also the financial
incentives you know through chinese
capital like
investment and you know so it's it's
it's absolutely
uh not surprising to me i think what
what surprised me
um and and i was aware of the tweeting
and i was aware of all the the
um you know wolf warrior diplomacy and
all the propaganda that went around the
chronovirus
but what really impressed me about your
report was that you
took the time to show also the influence
that the chinese communist party had
on the reporting on the on the dealing
with the with the virus on the
pharmaceutical industry and it really
was the first time
comprehensively you began to see
how this works across an entire
industry and that's that's because i'd
seen it in
in in a microcosm before and i
understood
you know that it existed in the macro
but your report was the first time that
i
actually understood okay here's how it
all
works and how it all fits together in a
macro sense for this one specific
industry
i literally heard from billionaires and
this is before
you know long before the coronavirus in
here in the united states that you know
our uh our system of governments failed
we need to adopt the chinese system of
government so it's not surprising to me
that um this would actually be you know
people would say oh they've got a much
better system of government you know one
one party controls everything you know
and
and if you look in our system the two
parties you know essentially fight each
other
and say you know they want each party
wants the ability to have what the
chinese communist party has which is
total control over the society
and so it's not it's not a surprise to
me that they have
you know really um you know enjoyed this
kind of newfound power
uh that they got because of the
coronavirus so are you ta are you doing
any
anything in the legal sphere or are you
just focused mainly on kind of the
educational part of it you know this
report tweeting
or are you actually working to fight
some of these cases through the legal
system
personally i'm not uh some of my
colleagues are
but to me it's really the geopolitical
aspect that interests me the most um
the influence of china in particular and
that's not something that's really um
it's really conducive to you know being
dealt with through
courts i mean frankly you know the
chinese communist party is kind of
above the law in that sense um that's
that's the problem that's
that's the thing i can tell you some
stories about that right
right um there is a case that people are
talking about filing a big civil case
uh suing the suing china for all the
damage that has been done
through these lockdowns um but you know
that is um a quixotic
case that's not really it's more about
bringing attention it's just another way
of bringing attention
i'd rather just sort of report on this
um and sort of the geopolitical aspect
and shed light on that there's other
attorneys you know
some i'd say you know older more
experienced attorneys
are actually dealing with um the more
domestic side you know suing companies
for
uh these tests and hoping to get some
profitable class action lawsuits
uh that's kind of doesn't interest me as
much i think it's very profitable
uh also very time consuming i mean but
if you're the type of attorney who's
used to going up against giant
corporations and
big class action lawsuits potentially
very profitable go into and that'll be
an essential part of the process of
getting back to normal
and shedding light on this catastrophe
is those big civil
class action suits that to me is not as
interesting as sort of what's going on
geopolitically to me the big story is
that
this has shed light on how much
influence the
chinese communist party has um there are
people
who you know yourself and others who
a very niche community who is aware of
this for one reason or another
uh i had absolutely no idea that the
chinese communist party had
this much influence on our world and but
i mean this is the real wake-up call i
mean the chinese communist party just
shut down the world
like you know i like the have you seen
the pit bull interview
when when when he says they they they
they took control of the world with a
virus i mean it was
it was a really really powerful
interview you know he comes from
communism
and he's like i see what's going on here
and uh he's a real
you know of course a popular figure but
you know when people like that begin to
see it and and speak out about it
you know i'm i'm hopeful that you know
we're nearing kind of the end of this
madness where people are going to wake
up and realize but you mentioned
something early in the interview
about the intelligence community and and
i can tell you having worked a lot with
the intelligence community in my time in
uniform
that you know when it comes to this they
are
completely clueless because the things
that you researched and looked at
are not the things that they research
and look at and certainly
that's been one of the problems with our
intelligence community is that they
haven't
been tied in to in many
cases because they're prevented from
looking at
our own society and so when you can't
look at our own society and see
the the the implications of chinese
influence within it then you
tend to not have the ability to kind of
warn us and and this has been i think
the big challenge within
washington dc because you know like at
the national security council any
national security council meeting the
first
the first thing you're going to get is
an intelligence briefing what is that
what does the intel community think
about a b
or c in this case they didn't even
they didn't even you know it was
entirely within the like the national
institute of
health in the cdc it wasn't within um
the intelligence community
they i think in in many respects
completely missed
um this so you know it's almost you
you're providing you know i said the
fourth estate
which you know pertains to the press but
it's also
um it's all you're almost doing an
intelligence committee
um community uh effort here to identify
um this type of uh bad you know bad
behavior that's a national security
challenge
within our own society one of the things
that i saw in taiwan and i actually got
the coronavirus in taiwan very in late
january
of 2020 and i was there to monitor
elections
they had established non-governmental
organizations that were
designed to focus on
chinese influence within taiwan in
addition they were some of the first to
react to
the coronavirus but they didn't react in
the way that the
communist party did they basically did
exactly what you said
it tells people to voluntarily wash your
hands you know social distance use mass
whatever
made them aware but you know there was
no lockdown
there to this day has never been a
lockdown in taiwan so
um i think in terms of you know
the intelligence community and
non-governmental organizations how do
you
you know if you're not going to attack
this from the um
from the the courts how do we establish
this more
permanent presence of you know
the fourth estate has failed i mean
clearly you know
veritas goes around trying to do its bit
you've done
you know i think a a noble effort here
but
by and large the media is not the media
anymore how do we create this
this real kind of non-governmental
organization
or organizations that are focused on
alerting our society to things that
happen as
a condition of globalization in the
internet where we are uh interlinked
with
particularly totalitarian societies that
have an interest to
undermine our democracies
i mean it's a great question i
i don't know if i have all the answers i
mean i agree 100
that this is first and foremost an
intelligence failure
i think lockdowns are first and foremost
a crime an
unprecedented crime and a fraud and also
first and foremost intelligent failure
the big reason that i think most people
are going along with it is they think
that if there was anything untoward
about it
the intelligence community would say so
and that just sort of feeds on itself i
think scientists think well you know if
the chinese communist party was
influencing us somehow
um you know the scientists who are would
say so
yeah that you know yeah the fbp i would
say sora or mr5 would say sorry one of
the many intelligence
agencies would say so of course folks in
the intelligence community know that
that's not really what they do
and also they're affected by the exact
same thing this you know
wolf in sheep's clothing that public
health just isn't something you think
about
as being geopolitical it's this very
sort of innocent collaborative field
that
um you know people go into it they
aren't thinking about
geopolitics and competition and
totalitarianism
they're thinking about how they can save
lives and that's why people go into
public health that's sort of the most
innocent collaborative
um international field and unfortunately
that is exactly what made it so
appealing to the chinese communist party
they've been colonizing it for many
years now
uh whether they had exactly this plan in
mind or if it was just sort of
because they knew that um
that because public health was so
unexpected
that it was the sort of um innocent
field where you don't expect this type
of
geopolitical influence they knew that
they could sort of use
public health as the perfect sort of
propaganda piece
that these people are you know you can
almost say a bit gullible because they
um you know doctors they work in a
collaborative field they tend to be
a little bit vulnerable to financial
scams for that same reason
uh that they just are a bit unsuspecting
about
you know fraud they're trusting yeah
they're very trusting at the same time
they enjoy a very
very high degree of trust from the
public so
you can see if you're sort of a criminal
mastermind which which
frankly is what the chinese communist
party is you can see how that's kind of
the
perfect conduit to turn lies into truth
a sort of perfect propaganda conduit by
corrupting public health
um and unfortunately that's what we've
seen over the past year
how do we combat that um you know
a day at a time i think in the short
term
we have to shed light on what's actually
happened here um
once people are aware it does seem like
the narrative of the lockdown fraud
is coming apart more and more eyes are
opening up you know i'm getting
you know exponentially more followers by
the day interested in how china has
influenced this
people you know the mainstream press
it's very clear
they're getting a bit nervous because
people have just turned their backs on
them
and they're just so stubborn about
not covering anything that goes against
the narrative of these lockdowns being
absolutely necessary
and there are multiple reasons for that
someone is that is
their financing from china so it is
because
you know even more other financing comes
from corporations with financial
interests in china
and they will report on things that are
you know universally known to be
important they're they actually do a
fairly good job of reporting on china's
human rights abuses i think everybody
knows that there's
genocide going on there and that's
testament to that being very important
to everybody i mean i
actually did something i mean i think
the fact that they're you know
chinese communist party is committing
genocide should be born enough reason
to uh decouple i really hoped we had
learned that
lesson from the 1930s but apparently we
have not so i mean
my work shouldn't really be necessary in
that sense we should already be
decoupling from china for
that reason alone that they're
committing genocide but i think people
need something that
hits more closer to home to actually
initiate that
and you know the truth is in 2020 that's
exactly what happened this is something
that affect everybody's lives
but so there's that financial interest
from the chinese communist party
financial interest from corporations and
also group think
in itself you know no journalist wants
to step out of line
because they don't see any other
journalists stepping on the line
uh they see you know talking about
the lockdowns being really bad or
talking about chinese communist party
influence on lockdowns
they see that is sort of a niche sort of
out there topic
that frankly people like me write about
but mainstream journalists just don't
and that's the way it is that's the
narrative um
and so there's some of that groupthink
amongst them as well they're in some
ways even more vulnerable to it
because they see themselves as
responsible
for being the mainstream i think a lot
of politicians see themselves that way
as well from
the conversations that sides have have
with them
they see themselves as being responsible
for sort of holding that
center line holding that narrative
intact and they can't sort of they feel
like they can't step out of lines that
sort of makes them even more vulnerable
to group thing in that sense
so you know make no mistake even though
the chinese communist party was
sort of but for cause there's no
question that they invented the idea of
lockdown
thus it's axiomatic that the world would
not be in lockdown if not for them and
they also you know
um the fake science journals you know
seem to have influenced the data seem to
have launched the giant propaganda
campaign
but it's also group think you know
dictatorships are excellent at using
groupthink against people using
groupthink to control
so when people argue that you know i
just don't think that it's really
china's influence so much i think it's
just you know there's a lot of evidence
this is just group thing people are
doing this because
they see other people doing they see
their peers doing it they see especially
their powerful peers who they want to
impress doing it
that's absolutely true but that's how
all dictatorships work
all their teachers work through group
thing all dictators are in some ways
you know psychological masterminds of
using a weaponizing group thing to their
own advantage of keeping themselves in
power
so those two things are not mutually
exclusive yes
it is you know 90 group thing but yes
the chinese communist party did sort of
in my mind deliberately
instigate that for their own for their
own ends
so um have you read the book red notice
by bill browder
um so it's it's a story about
the the how he fought
um after um one of his attorneys
magnitsky you you may he may that may
so magnifique was killed by um by
putin's uh
henchman um he started this whole
you know effort to go after the
magnitsky act and it's really defined
his life
and he's fought for um
on behalf of this so is this is this
kind of where where you kind of
diverge in your life do you see this
becoming your life's work or
are you just trying to put things kind
of back and back in place and you're
going to go on i mean it's a
i mean you've taken on probably the most
powerful regime in the world
in in some respects and um and
so so how do you see how do you see this
playing out personally
i don't know where it's going to take me
um i could see it going either way i
could see myself
uh going back to normal or i could see
myself sort of dedicating myself to this
i will pursue this particular story for
as long as it takes
because to me this is the biggest crime
of the century so far
um you know that is you only get so many
exclamation points in life
is my big exclamation point that you
know xin ping
the chinese communist party just shut
down the world um
they did it in my mind deliberately and
um you know now you have
millions starving children who would not
be otherwise if we're not for this
influence operation
that is a big deal and until people know
that
until that is common knowledge you know
i that's unacceptable to me living in a
world where
somebody might actually be able to get
away with that and to see
journalists in the leads covering for
them is absolutely disturbing to me i've
lost you know
a lot of respect for people who i used
to listen to i had no reason not to
um you know like i said i was kind of a
new york times economist reader
i had no reason not to trust those
people that's the people who
you know my parents generation told me
that you know i should
trust their judgment uh they wrote very
well they have very good grammar
um they you know seem to know a lot
about different countries and about the
world and so you know i'd listen to them
and listen to their opinions
uh and i have lost a lot of respect for
those writers now because they have not
been willing
they have given the circumstances when
it
um behoove their interest they have been
turned into propaganda outlets very
deliberately
by a totalitarian regime i think
um they to my knowledge were not before
but that has been how powerful this
deliberate fraud
and psychological operation has been um
by maintaining that big lie that this
virus is exceptional
and it requires these exceptional
measures and this is all necessary
that's what our elites really want us to
believe they want us to all to go along
with that and especially
you know their professional class they
want the professional class to really
buy into that and
you know you weren't as a lawyer as a
doctor you weren't really affected by
this financially
so just do us you know do us a favor and
pretend that this is all necessary
pretend you don't see the data pretend
you don't see
all the fraud and propaganda that has
taken place
and so we can just keep the sort of
structure of things intact
anyway the stock market is fine anyway
so you should be you should be okay
um that's not acceptable to me i i'm not
going to
rest and just let them get away with
this crime that you know to me
was very deliberate on the part of um
probably a very small powerful circle
within chinese communist party
maybe a handful of collaborators and
then from there
spun into um this big lie
that you know the suspension of all
human rights was
necessary and people have bought into
that and
essentially become criminals themselves
and that's what dictatorships
sell at is bringing out the evil in
ordinary people
and that's what we see more and more of
and you know
fortunately i think people are waking up
at that and realizing what's going on
here and i think that
that big lie is going to uh hopefully
self-destruct very soon
well i hope so and mike i'd just like to
say thank you um i
thank you uh for educating me because it
was really your report that really
allowed me to extend my site deeper into
what the chinese communist party was
doing thank you for coming on
generally speaking and i appreciate your
efforts
i'll keep supporting you on twitter and
thank you
and we'll post uh links to your twitter
account uh with this
with this video and look forward to
talking to you again very soon
thanks so much general yeah your support
has been invaluable i think you know
we've only scratched the surface of what
the chinese communist party's influence
has been on this panama response and in
the world at large so
i mean there's much more to come i'm
sure i'm sure
thank you so much thanks general take
care if you stayed at the end of this
video
i hope you enjoyed it be sure to leave
comments below
like and subscribe so you can get access
to
notifications when the next video comes
out i hope you enjoyed the conversation
with mike singer he's doing great work
exposing
the chinese communist party's influence
on our society thanks again for
joining us with generally speaking i'm
general spalding
[Music]
you